i speak about the watchmakers a lot
because it's something i want like kids
to aspire to be there's only so little
left in this world they're like samurais
we can't let the samurais die we gotta
have kids want to become
watchmakers
my name is ruiji villa senor um creative
director and ceo of root been a watch
collector since i was
a little boy seven years old five seven
years old i have a photo where i'm
wearing a power rangers watch and i
collected like batman power ranger you
know things that i could beg my parents
for it was like a superhero gadget to me
and then i went to go you know wear my
father's like cartier tanks and
raymond weil or whatever like all these
different watches that he collected
definitely not with his permission yeah
i went
i would put him on in his bedroom linger
around to see if you'd notice toss you
know the trash you wouldn't notice
pretty soon like the trash turned into
i'm gonna go out with my friends i gotta
level up i can't keep wearing uh you
know i can't keep wearing power ranger
watches
this watch that i'm wearing is a rolex
nicknamed tutti frutti but it's actually
a rolex yacht master and it's named
tutti frutti because of the various
crystals on it diamonds rubies and all
the other fun stuff my favorite thing
about this watch it is a large statement
piece but meant for something sport kind
of a
direct reference to what i do with root
where we disrupt luxury with sportswear
references i feel like thanos with all
the crystals i feel like i've got all
the superpowers in the world i mean i'd
wear this to a gq interview you know
i've worn it in lake como summertime
took up april sprints in the middle of
the lake and listen to music awesome
it's waterproof right it looks like it
shouldn't be waterproof but it is it's
waterproof
this is a audemars piguet perpetual
calendar open work i think it would be
the grandfather of
the skeleton ap skeleton would mean you
know when a watch is skeletonized it
exposes all the inner workings of the
movement and this was one of the first
with the perpetual calendar which tells
the day the month and the date like what
the fact that it has like that moon and
like that's that's showstopper this
feels like doctor strange of watches
first thing i think of when i look at
this watch is um
morale front and video
the girl he had the bbct because that
bbct to me changed the way i looked at
clubs i was like wow that minute that
happened we're like wow this is a new
era of streetwear i got a
great great deal a buddy of mine was you
know i hate that it has to be that way
but he was strapped for cash
and i was like well
i need that watch and he didn't even
like it he didn't even really wear it
and he didn't understand the importance
of it boom the christies just put one up
and now it just skyrocketed the value of
it i wouldn't sell back to him not a
chance dude i got a story where i was at
uh jay's office
and i had this whole fit right i was
wearing this watch
and jay's got the craziest collection
i'm in the office and we're talking he's
so quick he sees my watch i'm like yeah
next day he's at the game with this
watch and i was like this guy i can't
wait against that no way i like the
metal band i can't break the filipino
out of me bro we just love gold you know
steel like performs best in the market
aftermarket sell through all that
but the gold in me is just like dude
right why is that damn
[Music]
let me just wind it so this is manual
winding it's so weird right this is a
concept ap one of the first concepts
that audemars piguet made this was a
dream watch of mine you know how car
companies have the their concept cars
the way the future will look like this
is one of the concepts that
automatically get put together i look at
this watch and i think about just the
tedious hand work that you know the
watchmaker had to do just to create this
movement there's only two things i think
with such steady hands is brain surgeon
or a watchmaker i like to look at the
watches as i'm designing and this is
something that i think will be the
reference point to the designs for what
i'm doing next at one point this was the
pinnacle of watchmaking but the game
evolves and this still to me stance is
the best it's like a bat mobile on the
wrist i think i take this watch off more
than i wear it because i like looking at
it as a whole you get comfortable
no
no no
do i get i feel like guys compliment me
more than you know women do they're like
that's a great watch girls are like so
big
patek is the greatest brand ever created
this is a 5980 1r patek philippe to me
speaks
luxury at the utmost i think they
believe in
you know the proper watchmaking that
they do and um i think by design they
make the best dress watches yeah given
that this isn't a dress watch but yeah
this is a sport watch i don't even know
maybe i think it's for sailing i don't
know i can't sit up here and lie i don't
know what this watch is meant for but
this was my 30th
yeah i don't even i try not to say 30th
but this is my birthday gift this watch
is special because it's um influences
the way i uh i act two most like sought
out watches is probably skeleton either
one of the skeletons open work perpetual
and then this the 5980.
[Music]
this is a rolex gmt it's called a batman
it's a 2020 one of my steel collections
and this is a new project that i'm
working on called rework rhe work it's
me
curating a selection of watches that i'm
really passionate about or have grown
real close to just adding a little
slight design detail that i think should
have been done to the watch better than
the original but maintaining uh the
heritage and the real design value of it
it's the singer of watches i guess
porsche singer of watches i go back to
that kid that used to wear the batman
watches and power rangers and i think
the most iconic batman colors would be
black blue and yellow but they tend to
skip out on the yellow so we made this
watch and this to me is the better
batman this is like the 80s batman
version of it ties it back to the yellow
drawstring that we do for root we
obviously work with an aed to take out
the movement but then for the gmt
because it's everything is all kind of
intertwined we have to be so tedious
with it and then i was either going to
hand paint the dials and do the whole
thing but since this was the first watch
we were going to do the project on
i was a little nervous i don't know you
buy a porsche you know
72 porsche you know air-cooled and then
you just try to mess with the inside and
then you just destroy the whole inside
you got to buy a new engine blah blah
blah and it's not the same watch anymore
it still speaks to the watch collectors
but it's personalized for me and this is
the
second of the
how many do we do four or five yeah or
five of the reworks
this is a stellar dial day-date rolex
it's a vintage first watch i ever
purchased the band was so flimsy that
you know like when you put it like this
it was like i just decided to part ways
with it it was a presidential band
and so we put a leather strap because
leather straps are ten times better than
metal straps i think i think they're way
classier beyond the strap we just um we
changed the the dial to stella because
it just was champagne dial and then we
did it into a blue stella dial and uh
engraved root in the back reworked one
of one but yeah this reminds me of
the days where i made my first money
with rude and i spent the whole thing on
watches and cars
without a business manager i was like
how much did i make buy the whole thing
you know and then you're like wait i'm
back to zero so there was a time where i
was like man i'm about to part ways with
you to get back but what i just spent i
can't part ways with it yet you know
these are watches that i have real real
um relationships with you know they're
like they're part of me so for me to
part ways with them would be like me
telling you to part where's your
favorite shirt